the old economy still dominates in North
Korea vast factories churning out basic
products like this copper cable maker in
Pyongyang the country exports some
commodities though far fewer now than
its biggest trading partner China has
banned most import in line with UN
sanctions it makes money by sending
laborers abroad it also relies heavily
on agriculture but in Pyongyang at least
there have been some notable changes new
buildings have sprung up there are more
cars on the road and there's a growing
choice of shops and restaurants we got
to ride in a city taxi operated by one
of the country's multiple government
controlled cab firms even the public
transport system has seen some minor
upgrades
we're inside the Pyongyang metro it's
big its grand there's lots of people
using it but they're still relying on
these very old German trains now they
have introduced DPRK made trains they
say that's a sign of the economic
development here
passengers can also now swipe in rather
than relying on paper tickets back on
the city streets there's evidence of a
more significant technological upgrade
Pyongyang's residents are avid
smartphone users and they can out choose
from a number of different brands we
visited this store selling the arirang
make supposedly produced here in North
Korea
the top model costs around $400 and
comes pre-loaded with an Android
operating system and a host of apps
including five versions of Angry Birds
but as is often the case in North Korea
things are not always what they seem
international calls are blocked on cell
phones here and the only surfer you can
do is on the government-controlled
intranet for bloomberg news I'm Tom
Mackenzie in Pyongyang